Well, I'm certainly glad you're here.
How many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock?
Well, I'll tell you what, you're my kind
of people because I grew up on a farm in
West St. Louis County and as we started
out with beef calves and if if you raise
livestock, the only way you can make
money is if you raise a lot of your own
feed for those of you don't have that
experience.
And so we raised our own corn and we
raised our own soybeans and our own hay.
And we had a truck come out from the
mill and this truck would come out from
the mill and it would grind up the corn
and the soybeans and the hay and then we
would add sacks of vitamins, minerals,
trace minerals and we'd make pellets out
of it and this is what we would feed the
calves. In six months time we'd ship
them to market to be slaughtered and
we'd save back some of the best ones for
ourselves. We'd knock them in the head
and eat them.
Put it bluntly.
And it always fascinated me as a
teenager that we did that for those
calves and then six months ship them off
to be slaughtered or we'd eat them.
And we want to live to be 100 years of
age without any
aches and pains and guess what? We
didn't take any vitamins or minerals.
And that bothered me.
So I asked my dad, I'd say, "Hey Pops,
how come you do that for those calves
you don't do that for us?"
And he'd give me this good old Missouri
farm wisdom. He'd say things like, "Shut
up, boy. You're getting this farm fresh
food and we hope you appreciate it."
And of course I was very quiet then cuz
I didn't want to miss out on any meals.
Well, then when I went to school, I went
to the University of Missouri School of
Agriculture and I got my degree in
agriculture. I got my major in animal
husbandry and nutrition. My minor was in
field crops and soils and then I got
into veterinary school.
As a freshman veterinary student I
learned the answer to my question.
And the answer is this. We know how to
prevent and cure diseases in animals
with nutrition. And the reason why we do
that is because we don't have major
medical. We don't have hospitalization,
Blue Cross, Blue Shield. We don't have
Medicare.
If you're going to make money as a
farmer, you better know how to do stuff
yourself and you better do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can.
To make a long story short, after I got
out of veterinary school, I went to
Africa for 2 years and I was able to
fulfill a boyhood dream. I was able to
be a Frank Buck for 2 years and work
with Marlin Perkins. Many of you will
remember him from the Mutual of Omaha's
Wild Kingdom and he's a great gentleman.
And after 2 years of working with
elephants and rhino, people used to ask
me, "Are Are you a small animal vet or a
large animal vet?" Well, I used to tell
them I'm a extra large animal vet cuz I
worked with elephants and rhinos.
Well, after 2 years, he sent me a
telegram and said, "Would you come back
to the St. Louis Zoo and work with us?
We need a wildlife veterinarian at the
zoo for a special project. We're given a
7 and 1/2 million-dollar grant from the
National Institutes of Health and what
we need is a veterinarian who'll do
autopsies of animals that die of natural
causes in the zoo."
Well, I was just overjoyed to do that
and so I came back and and of course I
would not only did autopsies for animals
that died in the St. Louis Zoo, but the
Brookfield Zoo in Chicago, the Bronx Zoo
in New York, the National Zoo, the LA
Zoo and so forth. And my job again was
to do autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the zoo and look for a
species of animals that was
ultra-sensitive to pollution.
This is because during the early '60s,
we had just learned about pollution and
ecological problems and disasters and
nobody quite knew what to do and so I
was supposed to find a species of
animals that was extra-sensitive
and use them much like we did the
canaries in the mine. You know, the old
Welsh coal miners used to put a canary
in a little wicker cage and take it down
in the mine and if methane gas or carbon
monoxide would leak into the mine, the
canary would drop off the perch and die
first and the man knew to get out before
the mine blew up or they suffocated.
Again, to make a long story short, over
a period of some 12 years, I did 17,500
autopsies in over 454 species of animals
and 3,000 human beings who lived in
close proximity to zoos.
And the thing that I found out was this,
every animal and human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency.
And that fascinated me. I went back took
me back to those calves. I said, "Gee,
that's fascinating. We could document
this at autopsy both chemically and
biochemically and things that you saw
with the eye at the autopsy table."
Well, that fascinated me and I wrote
scientific articles. I wrote eight
multi-author textbooks and one textbook
of my own cost 140 bucks for medical
students and I'm sure the only thing
they do is use them for doorstops.
And I couldn't get anybody excited. I
was on 20/20.
Uh I was on 1,700 newspapers.
I was in magazines. I was in every
network TV that you can think of and
guess what? Couldn't get anybody excited
back in the '60s about nutrition.
So, what I did was went back to school
and became a physician to use everything
I'd learned in veterinary school about
nutrition in my human patients.
And to no surprise to me, it worked.
Spent 12 years up in Portland, Oregon in
general practice.
And um it was very fascinating. What I'm
going to share with you tonight is what
I learned over those 10 12 years using
nutrition with my human patients.
And if you take home only 10% it will
save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery. It will save you a
gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means. A gob
means a lot.
Okay, it'll add many healthful years to
your life.
Well, you can't do this. You can't get
these healthful years. You can't have
longevity. You can't live to your
genetic potential just falling off a
stump.
Uh you have to do some things. The first
thing I have to do is convince you that
it is worth
doing these things. Now, I'm going to
start out by convincing you that the
genetic potential for human beings is
120 years, our genetic potential for
longevity. In May 11th, the oldest
living American at this time and
documented uh through the Guinness World
Book of Records was Margaret Skeete. She
was from Radford, Virginia. She died at
age 115.
And she died of a nutritional
deficiency. You can tell that from her
her obituary.
Uh she died of the complications of a
fall.
What did she die from? Osteoporosis,
very good. She died of a calcium
deficiency. She had no heart no cancer,
no diabetes, no other infirmities.
But she died 3 weeks after a fall cuz
she didn't have enough calcium.
Her daughter said that she had a craving
for sweets until she died and that's a a
disease called pica. We'll talk about
that in a little bit, but usually when
you have a craving for chocolate, if
you're a chocoholic or a sugarholic, uh
that means that you have a deficiency of
Then in a third world country in Niger,
in Africa, a chief by the name of Bauer
at age 126 was eulogized by one of his
wives and she was bragging about him at
his death at age 126. He was still in
possession of all his own teeth. Okay,
so you assume that other faculties are
working, too.
Then here's a gentleman uh from Syria.
At age 133, he died in July of 1993. He
fathered nine children after the age of
80. And this meant to view add up nine
months for each child and the year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children, he was
still fathering children after age of
100. So there's still hope for you,
fellows.
Then those of you who like science, um
in November of 1993,
those six biospherians came out of that
dome in Arizona. They were in there for
2 years, three couples, and they were
supposed to eat the perfect food and
recycle the atmosphere and grow their
own food and whatnot and have no
pollution in their water, or air, or
food. And when they came out, they were
examined by medical gerontologist from
UCLA, University of California at Los
Angeles. They put all this information,
their physical, and their blood work,
and so forth into the medical computers
at UCLA, and the medical computers
projected that they could live to be 165
years old if they continued to do what
they were doing. So, all of that just
says to you that there's a there's a
possibility you can live to be 120. And
when I grew up on the farm, we could
grow 200 uh bushels of corn per acre,
and with all the labor and all the
fertilizers and everything else you did,
you could make a profit if you grew 200
bushels per acre. But, if you only got
100 bushels per acre and put out that
same effort and the same fertilizer
cost, you'd lose money.
And so, I want you to think about it.
The average lifespan for an American
today is 75.5.
The average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is 58.
You want to gain 20 years statistically,
just don't go to medical school.
You want to live to be 120, there's only
two basic things. They're real simple.
Two things to remember. Number one, you
have to avoid the pitfalls. You have to
not step on the land mines, I call it.
And those of you in the military, you
know what that means. You do something
stupid like step on one of those things,
you kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily. And of course, if you
play Russian roulette or smoke
excessively or drink excessively or wear
a black sweatsuit and run down the
middle of the highway at 2:00 in the
morning, you're going to get struck by a
car. Uh all of those things are
foolhardy, but it's amazing how many
tens of thousands of people die in
America from doing those stupid things
every year. The last thing I will share
with you on that subject of avoiding the
land mines, I suggest very strongly to
you that you avoid going to doctors.
And I'm going to back up that statement,
which is a pretty strong statement, from
Ralph Nader's group in January of 1993,
just about a year and a half ago, uh
January 13th, he put out a news release
based on a 3-year study on the causes of
death in American hospitals. And it was
1,500 page report, this 3-year study,
and I'm not going to waste your time or
mine by going over the whole thing word
for word, but the bottom line says a
lot. Quote, "300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence." Unquote.
I'm going to read that figure again cuz
it's a huge figure. Quote, "300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence."
Unquote. Now, he didn't say slipped away
quietly out of neglect in the corner
somewhere while they're waiting for an
x-ray. He used the word killed. When you
use the word killed, that means there
was a procedure the doctor was doing
went wrong somehow. That means that they
gave them a wrong prescription. They put
a decimal point in the wrong spot and
gave them an incorrect dosage. These
people were killed.
300,000. To appreciate how big a figure
that is, you have to compare that with
our military losses in Vietnam over 10
years, where we lost 56,000 people over
10 years or an average of only 5,600 a
year
on a field of battle where people had
guns and artillery and explosives trying
to kill each other.
And millions of people poured out into
the streets and protested that war. We
had political anarchy in the last 3
years of the war. Students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives. National Guardsmen shot
students at Kent State in Ohio.
We chased a president out of the
presidency for 5,600 military personnel
a year. And here's one profession that
takes your tax money
in the form of Medicare and Medicaid and
kills 300,000 of us a year according to
Ralph Nader, and I believe him. He has
no axe to grind.
And you can go out in the street any day
of the week in any city, and there isn't
even a crazy street preacher out there
with a sign that says protect us from
doctors.
I want you to think about that, folks.
That's number one.
You have to avoid stepping on the land
mine. So, there's a certain value in
treating yourself when you can. Or
preventing disease so you don't have to
get treated. Now, the second thing you
have to do, number two, is you have to
do the positive things. You have to do
the positive things.
And I'm going to start out here by just
putting a figure up on the board. It's
the number 90.
And you need 90 nutrients in your diet
every day. You need 60 minerals. You
need 16 vitamins. You need 12 essential
amino acids or protein building blocks.
And you need three essential fatty
acids. You need 90 nutrients in your
daily diet. Otherwise, you're going to
get a deficiency disease if you don't
have them in complete numbers and
optimal amounts.
I can tell you that I was one of those
nerds back when I was in college. I had
a clipboard. We didn't have computers
back then. So, I had a clipboard and I I
was one of those funny guys with glasses
and would walk up and down in the
student union there in Columbia and say,
"Uh, do you take vitamins and minerals?"
I was still fascinated by that. And And
of course, people would kind of look at
you crazy and say, "Well, yeah, I take
vitamin E."
And I'd wait for them to come up with
the other 89 and they didn't. They just
Oh, I take vitamin E.
Well, today if you ask people, "Do you
take food supplements?" They say, "Oh,
yeah, I take Tums."
Because that's what, you know, they hear
all the time. Well, again, you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it.
But, the newspapers know and the
magazines and TV and radio knows that
we're interested in health and longevity
and and supplements. So, they all talk
to us not because the medical profession
has asked them to do that in their
stead. The medical profession doesn't
say, "Hey, we're so busy saving people
with surgery and chemotherapy and
radiation and pharmaceuticals, would you
please educate the people on nutrition?"
They do it because it sells newspapers.
Well, my favorite article of all time
appeared in Time magazine April 6th,
1992. And if you haven't read it, I'd
urge you to get it out of the school
library or public library and photocopy
it. Stick one copy on the door in the
bathroom and one on the refrigerator.
It's a cover article and it says, "The
real power of vitamins. New research
shows they may help fight cancer, heart
disease, and the ravages of aging."
Again, there's six positive pages in
here. There's only one negative sentence
and was issued by a medical doctor who
was asked by the writer of the article,
"What do you think What do you think
about vitamins and minerals for people
as food supplements?" And here's what
the doctor said, quote, "Popping
vitamins doesn't do you any good."
sniffs Dr. Victor Herbert, a professor
of medicine at New York City's Mount
Sinai Medical School. "We get all the
vitamins we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine." unquote. Well, to give you a
Missouri translation of that, that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals. You
might as well wad up your dollars and
throw them in the toilet and flush them
away cuz you're not getting any
redeeming value from it. Those quacks
are just taking your money for those
vitamins and minerals.
That's what he was trying to say. Got
published.
So, it must be true, right?
After having done those 17,500
autopsies in 454 species of animals from
around the world and then 3,000 humans
and liking to be healthy myself and
having children and grandchildren and
not too distant future
great-grandchildren, I'd rather pee out
50 cents or a dollar a day worth of
excess vitamins and minerals. It's
pretty cheap insurance.
If you don't invest in yourself to the
tune of a buck a day for vitamins and
minerals, guess what? You're going to
invest in the lifestyle of a MD
somewhere.
Cuz when you pay the medical doctor your
fee for going to see him,
not one penny of that goes to study how
to diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease in a little child
like who was in here earlier or how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer prostate cancer in adults.
Guess what that money goes for? Pays the
doctor's mortgage. Makes his Mercedes
payment. It pays the tuition for his
kids to go to medical school at Harvard.
You know what Harvard is? Up in Boston.
Pays the tuition for his kids to go to
law school at Yale. Between 1776 and the
Second World War,
the US government spent $80 million
dollars on health care and health care
research and studies.
Right now we're at 1.2
trillion dollars a year
for health care.
And it's free.
We all know it's free, right?
It's not free, but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff. I'll
tell you what, if we used a human type
medical system for the agricultural
industry and the livestock, your
hamburger would cost $275 a pound.
On the other hand, if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans,
your monthly insurance premiums for a
family of five would be $10 a month.
You take your choice.
Well, I believe since we've made them
wealthy through insurance programs and
government subsidies, I believe they owe
us something. I believe they owe us at
least as much as the industries do
according to, for instance, recall
notices. This was started, of course, I
don't know, 25 years ago when Ralph
Nader learned that the Ford Motor
Company had made a Pinto car with a rear
end gas tank that would blow up when you
got hit from behind at 20 miles an hour,
fry everybody in the car. And when
people complained to Ford Motor Company,
they said, "Well, you're just dumb for
getting in a car accident. We're not
going to pay you for that."
Ralph Nader says, "No, it's a faulty
design."
So, he went to a federal court and the
judge agreed with him and through a
court order forced Ford Motor Company to
send everybody a recall notice
with a registered letter, bring that car
in and we'll fix it for nothing.
But they kill 300,000 a year and nobody
protests as long as we get ours free.
And that scares me, that attitude. At
any rate,
I've got a bunch of these recall notices
you should have gotten over the last
couple years. I'll go through them
quickly. Number one is ulcers. How many
of you ever heard that ulcers is caused
by stress?
Okay, everybody's heard that. If you
don't raise your hand, you got
Alzheimer's or you're fibbing, right?
Well, we knew 50 years ago in in the
veterinary industry that ulcers, at
least in pigs, was caused by a bacteria
called Helicobacter pylori. And of
course, we couldn't get one of these
high-priced stomach surgeons from Mayo
Clinic. In fact, we always used to yell,
"Hold the mayo!" when they'd say stuff
like that. Otherwise, your pork chops
would be $275 a pound to pay for that
kind of surgery. And we learned that
with a trace mineral called bismuth and
a tetracycline antibiotic that we could
prevent and then and cure those stomach
ulcers in pigs without surgery. And so,
that's what we did. Cost five bucks to
cure a pig of stomach ulcers with the
bismuth, the trace mineral, and
tetracycline. Well, the National
Institutes of Health now, not the
National Enquirer, but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said, "Ulcers are
caused by a bacteria called Helicobacter
pylori, not stress."
And they can be cured. They actually
used the cure word in this news release.
Medical researchers never do that. They
always say, "It shows promising
results." or "May be beneficial." They
used the cure word, National Institutes
of Health. And they said, "Can be cured
with a combination of the trace mineral
bismuth and tetracycline."
Well, for those of you who don't know
what bismuth comes in, you can get it
from any grocery store or drugstore.
It's pink, about $2.95 for an 8-oz
bottle, and it's called Pepto-Bismol.
So, a teaspoon a day full of
Pepto-Bismol and some Aureomycin calf
scour pellets, you can take care ulcers.
Now, you have your choice whether you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get whittled on. It's your choice.
Then, what's the number two cause of
death in Americans? Terrible disease
called cancer, right?
Now, doctors get information on cancer,
you'd think they'd photocopy that and
when they send you that bill, they
should send you some photocopies of this
stuff. Well, in September of 1993, the
National Cancer Institute, not the
National Enquirer, but the National
Cancer Institute, and the
Harvard Medical School in Boston did a
study on cancer patients and they came
out and they said an anti-cancer diet
was found.
Well, anyway, they picked China to do
this study because in one province,
Henan province in China, they have the
highest rate of cancer in the whole
world. They took 29,000 people for 5
years in this study.
And what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals at
double the recommended daily allowance
for Americans. Now, that's a trivial
amount. For instance, they use vitamin C
for one group and of course the
RDA or recommended daily allowance for
vitamin C is 60 mg. Double that's going
to be 120 mg. You can't go into a health
food store and find a vitamin C tablet
or capsule for less than 500 mg for an
adult.
And of course Linus Pauling, the
gentleman with two Nobel prizes, says if
you want to prevent and treat cancer
with vitamin C, you got to use 10,000 mg
a day. Well, all the doctors who used to
argue with him back 35 years ago were
all dead. And today Linus Pauling is
still 94 and he works 14 hours a day, 7
days a week on his ranch in the Big Sur
in California and teaches at the
University of California, San Francisco.
So, you have to make up your choice
whether you're going to listen to the
dead doctors or Linus Pauling. Your
choice. Okay, vitamin C double the RDA,
nothing happened. Vitamin A double the
RDA, nothing happened. Zinc, riboflavin,
the trace mineral molybdenum, niacin,
nothing happened. In one group they got
a major benefit. In this group they got
three nutrients at one time. They got
vitamin E, they got beta carotene, and
the trace mineral selenium. They had
those three were at double the RDA. And
if you get a half a percent benefit in
any nutritional or pharmaceutical
experiment, you've made a major
improvement in humanity's life. And so,
these articles get published. So, I want
you to remember that statistic. A half a
percent is major benefit. Well, in this
group that received the vitamin E, beta
carotene, and selenium for 5 years,
deaths from all causes were reduced by
9%. Almost 10 out of every 100 or one
out of every 10 who were going to die in
that 5 years from any cause survived.
Then cancers, all cancers, 13% survived
who would have died without those three
nutrients.
So, 13 out of 100 lived who would have
died, and then the type of cancer that
was most prevalent in Henan province,
stomach and esophageal cancer, 21% lived
who would have died. 21 out of 100
lived. Now, to me those are significant
numbers, and your physician, for the
number two cause of death in America,
should have sent every one of you a
photocopy of that. At least give you the
information, even if he didn't want to
give you the advice, give you the
information, let you make up your own
mind.
Well, here's one I think is funny on one
hand, and then on the other side it
tells you the attitude of physicians.
This has to do with arthritis. It was in
September 24th, 1993, that it was
released. Again, it was from the Harvard
Medical School and the Boston VA
Hospital. How many of you in here have
ever been to a VA Hospital? Anybody in
this room? Okay, good. Well, you know,
the people who've been to a VA Hospital,
you have two opportunities to give your
life for your country.
Once on the field of battle, and the
other's in the VA Hospital, right?
Well, anyway, the title of the release
was chicken protein halts the swelling
and pain of arthritis in a patient
trial. And what they did, they took
people who failed to respond in any way
to medical treatment for arthritis.
These people got gold shots,
methotrexate, they got aspirin,
prednisone, cortisone, and everything
else you can think of, physical therapy.
And the only thing left for them
was joint replacement surgery.
Okay, now, before Harvard Medical School
and the VA Hospital was going to give it
to them, they said, "Look, we're looking
for some people who are willing to
suffer for 90 more days, just 3 months,
because we want to try something, a
short-term experiment." And they got 29
volunteers. And what they did for those
29 volunteers who failed to respond in
any way to medical treatment for
arthritis was they gave them a heaping
teaspoonful of ground-up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning. Just a heaping teaspoon of
ground-up chicken cartilage. And in 10
days, according to Harvard Medical
School, all the pain and inflammation
was gone. These are people who didn't
respond in any way to medical treatment.
In 30 days, they could open up a new
pickle jar that'd never been opened.
And 90 days, 3 months,
they had maximum return of function.
Here's the funny part. The funny part
comes by a statement of the guy who was
the director of that study from Harvard
Medical School and here's what he said,
quote, listen to the words, they're very
important, quote, after 3 months it was
clear that the drug was beneficial,
unquote. Because it worked, chicken
cartilage had become a drug.
You can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule, 20 patients,
and you can just see him calculating,
right?
That means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken,
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones, you're
practicing medicine without a license.
And if you go to a Kentucky Fried
Chicken in the middle of the night, in
the dark of the night, and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two 5-gallon feed
buckets full of chicken bones,
and you take them home with a hammer and
you pound off the ends of those bones
and dry your own cartilage in the
microwave, you know,
you're manufacturing a pharmaceutical
and the FDA's going to put you in jail.
Next time I come by here in 3 months,
you're going to run up on the stage and
hug me and kiss me if you got arthritis.
How many of you ever heard of
Alzheimer's disease? Everybody's heard
about it today.
50 years ago when I was a little kid,
there was no such thing as Alzheimer's
disease. It's a new disease, one of
those things that just sort of happened.
Now it's a major disease.
One out of every two people who reach
age 70 get Alzheimer's disease. Pretty
scary.
We learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages Alzheimer's disease in
livestock. You imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their heads saying,
"Why am I here?
Where is the feed box?" Because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day, you're losing money, right? So, we
learned in the agricultural industry
how to prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil. You say, " Well, like
that's crazy. High doses of vitamin E."
Well, you should have got a recall
notice from your doctor in July of 1992
because the University of California, I
mean, we're talking about sophisticated
research medical school here, University
of California, San Diego came out and
said, "Vitamin E eases memory loss in
Alzheimer's victims." Now, they're only
50 years behind on that from veterinary
medicine, so you might be safe for going
to a veterinarian.
Then, how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone? Anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone? Okay, I see a few
in here. What's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally when
you got your kidney stone?
Give up calcium. No dairy.
No dairy.
None of those vitamin mineral things
with calcium in them cuz they have the
stupid, naive, ignorant belief, that's
pretty
intense. They have the stupid, ignorant,
naive belief that the calcium in your
kidney stone comes from the calcium you
eat. When in fact, it comes from your
own bones when you have a raging calcium
deficiency, a raging osteoporosis, then
you get kidney stones. We learned years
ago in writing in the agricultural
industry, if you wanted to prevent
kidney stones in livestock, you better
give them more calcium. You better give
them more magnesium and more boron. Now,
the reason is, of course, bulls and
rams, male cattle and sheep have special
anatomy. When they get a kidney stone,
they die. They call it water belly. They
die. When you and I get a kidney stone,
we just wish we were dead.
But, no farmer's dumb enough to pay for
the feed for an animal and have it die
before he can either eat it or send it
to market. So, we learned how to prevent
those things. Well, you should have got
a recall notice from your doctor,
especially you people who have had
kidney stones. Your urologist should
have sent a notice to you.
This was March of 1993. It says uh
"Calcium limits kidney stone risk." And
this is from the Harvard Medical School
up in Boston, by the way.
"In a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head, researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones. In a study of
more than 45,000 people that who were
ranked into five categories, the group
that had the most calcium had no kidney
stones. Now, about 5 years ago when I
started out on this crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one time zone in the next and
all over, I knew I was going to get
crazy out there uh
doing this. Last year I was on the road
300 days out of the year, 300 out of 365
days. And so I decided I needed to have
a hobby that I could take with me. Every
time I get a little wacko, I could go in
my room and do this hobby and I'd be
okay, you know, it'd be kind of like
having a little piece of home with me
wherever I went. I wanted to have a
hobby that would uh
uh help other people. I didn't want to
collect baseball cards cuz I like
football. I didn't want to do just
crossword puzzles cuz it's good mental
exercise, but wouldn't help anybody
else. And um I couldn't take my compost
pile. I like to garden and the hotels
don't like that, you know.
So, I decided I was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and lawyers.
Now, as crazy as that sounds, remember I
told you the doctors live to an average
age of 58 and we live to 75.5. And
here's a group of people, professionals,
who pontificate you and tell you, "Well,
this is what you need to do. You need to
give up salt and uh no caffeine and you
need to not eat butter and eat margarine
and do all these crazy things." And they
die at age 58 on the average and anyway,
I got a few of them here, some of my
favorites. So, this is Dr. Stuart
Carwright, age 38. He dropped dead in
his home. He was a family practitioner
uh of a ruptured aneurysm. That's a
ballooning of an artery that's a
weakened artery because of the uh
fragmenting or the brittle condition of
the elastic fibers in arteries.
Just like when you hit a chuckhole with
your car tire and you break the cords in
there and you get a balloon,
he dropped dead like he was poleaxed,
okay, right in his home from a ruptured
aneurysm. Now, we learned in 19, oh, I
think it was, uh, '57,
aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency.
We had a pilot project turkeys and we
made complete food pellets where you put
all the 90 nutrients in there and the
first 13 weeks fully half of those
turkeys died. Farmers were out there
every morning picking them up by the
bushel basket. They took them to the
state diagnostic labs and they were
autopsied and they found out that they
all had died from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm.
So, they doubled the amount of copper in
there and the next year they didn't lose
a single turkey from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm. And they ran that experiment
in mice and rats and rabbits and dogs
and cats and, uh, calves and sheep and
pigs and whatnot and guess what? They
found out there's a whole series of
diseases that are caused by a copper
deficiency. Gray hair is the first sign.
When you start getting gray hair,
regardless of your age, you got a copper
deficiency. You get skin wrinkles
because the elastic fibers in your skin
are going. Those little crow's feet
around your eyes and facial and body
skin wrinkles, you can look like you're
a little prune drying up.
Okay?
Then, of course, there's the, um,
varicose veins.
That's caused by an elastic fiber
breakdown.
Then, of course, parts of your body
begin to sag. Under your arms, your
breasts, your bellies, your legs, all
this stuff starts sagging and you can go
to a cosmetic surgeon or plastic surgeon
if you want, but it's a lot cheaper and
a lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some copper.
Dr. Cartwright may have had a medical
degree, but he didn't have expensive
urine, so he died of something that even
a turkey wouldn't die from.
And here's one, this fellow, he was a
doctor's doctor, Dr. Martin Carter. He
almost made it. He died at age 57.
He, uh, got his medical degree from
Harvard Medical School and his PhD in
medicine from Yale. He was autopsied by
the best cuz he was a doctor's doctor.
He said, quote, "The cause of death was
a ruptured aortic aneurysm," said Dr.
Jules Hirsch of Rockefeller University
Hospital, unquote. What did he die from?
Copper deficiency. See, he didn't have
expensive urine, either. Then here's an
attorney. she was so famous, she was
from Detroit, age 44, Ellen Joyce Alter.
She was in the New York Times obituary.
She made the big time. And of course she
probably had steel buns because she
belonged to one of those private health
clubs. All these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little exercises.
But she didn't have expensive urine
because she died of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm.
When they don't do an autopsy, the
symptoms could be called a stroke or
subdural hemorrhage. But very frequently
they're caused by a ruptured aneurysm
which is a copper deficiency. She didn't
have expensive urine. How many of you
here have ever heard of a guy by the
name of Stuart Berger? Stuart Berger, he
he wrote five best selling books on
health and diets and nutrition. He got
his medical degree from Tufts Medical
School which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
Harvard Medical School. And the books he
wrote included the Southampton diet for
weight loss. He wrote for ever young, 20
years younger in 20 weeks and how to be
your own nutritionist. And he died at
age 40. How would you like to follow his
dietary practices?
He died at age 40 of cardiomyopathy
which is a selenium deficiency. The same
cause as white muscle disease or or
stiff lamb disease and any farmer can go
to a feed store and get selenium pellets
or selenium injections or things like
Selatok and BoSe and so forth.
And Dr. Stuart Berger, a guy who wrote
five best selling books on nutrition,
died of a nutritional deficiency. He
didn't have expensive urine. You can
prevent, totally prevent cardiomyopathy
for 10 cents a day. And if we don't do
it, we're malignant dumb I like to call
it. You're malignant dumb if you don't
take in 10 cents a day worth of
selenium. It's a waste of your life.
That's one of those land mines you can
avoid. The medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
cost $750,000.
I want you to think about that. They get
the heart free from a donor.
They get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives.
They use $2.50 worth of suture material.
And they charge you $750,000
for that procedure. Now, 6 months ago in
LA when they had the earthquake, they
were putting people in jail for 60 and
90 days for price gouging for selling
these terrified people a gallon of water
for $4.
They put them in jail for price gouging
for selling them a gallon of water for
four bucks.
Now, to me that's entrepreneurialism.
You know, that's being in business for
yourself. If you had a a way to distill
water and make water and you had a car
and you could get in there and sell
those people a gallon of water for four
bucks. Hey, more power to you. Because
if you go to a 7-Eleven and buy a quart
of Evian water, it's $1.29.
So, four of those quarts is five bucks.
Kind of interesting, isn't it? They said
it was price gouging because those
people were terrified. Well, talk about
a person who needs a new heart. They're
terrified. $750,000.
We should put those doctors in jail. But
we bow to them because oh, that's
high-tech medicine.
Out of 270 million people in America,
you save about 50 a year. Is that
cost-effective? I don't think so. Dr.
Stuart Berger didn't have expensive
urine. And here's the last one, and many
of you may know this woman.
Uh her name is Dr. Gail Clark. She was
age 47. She was the chief cardiologist
of the West Saint Louis County group of
hospitals.
Uh she was the chief cardiologist for
the um Saint Mary's Health Center in
Richmond Heights in Saint Louis County.
She was age 47. Guess what she died
from.
Heart attack. A cardiomyopathy heart
attack. You can just see her walking
down the hall. She's got the stethoscope
around her neck. You know, this is their
little status symbol. Got my stethoscope
around my neck. Back when I was in
school, they folded it up very bravely
and put it in their pocket. Boom! She
falls down. She has a heart attack right
in the hall. And of course, the nurses
scoop her up and put her on a gurney and
they call the technicians and another
doctor. Code three! Code three! Code
blue! Whatever it is. And they whip her
into the room. And uh you can hear them
Let's say you're a cardiac patient.
You're laying there, you're all hooked
up to the monitors and the IVs and and
you hear him say, "Okay, tear her
clothes off.
Okay, stand back."
"Didn't work, turn it up, stand back."
And then you hear that terrible sound
when you know that the
treatment didn't work.
The flatline when you know the heart is
gone.
Everybody walks out of the room dejected
and you say, "Nurse, nurse, what
happened next door?" And she says,
"Well, your cardiologist, you know, the
chief cardiologist of this hospital, age
47, Dr. Gail Clark, just died of a
cardiomyopathy, heart attack." You can
see all the patients are holding their
gowns.
And they're running out of that
hospital, leaving their watches and
their shoes and their
checkbooks and everything and their
plastic credit cards cuz they don't want
to get what Dr. Gail Clark got. To me,
the Reader's Digest is a magazine that
never says anything negative or bad
about anybody or any group. It's the
sweetest little magazine that ever was.
The September 1993 issue
features an article that says, "Can you
trust your doctor?" It lists 12 ways
that doctors scam your money. Now, I'll
let you read 11 of them yourself. I'll
give you the worst one. In addition
to their income from office fees and
surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization, doctors get a kickback
from the labs and the the x-ray labs and
clinics and hospitals, they get a
kickback of $421
every time they send you in for a CAT
scan or an MRI.
And doctors tell you, "Oh, we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine cuz if I miss something, uh you
know, one in 10 billion you're going to
sue me. So, I do this just to protect
myself." Well, if it was just to protect
themselves and you knew them and they
knew you, 90% of the people say, "Oh,
just skip it, doc. If you don't really
think it's necessary, let's save the
money." But, they got something more
than defensive medicine to worry about.
They get 421 bucks in a kickback for
every time they send you in for an MRI
or a CAT scan. Well, when I practiced
for 12 years up in Portland, somebody
come to me with a terrible headache,
never had one, I'd just walk up to them
and tap them on the sinuses and if they
collapse to their knees, I know they had
a sinus headache. Oh doc, why'd you do
that? Well, I just wanted That's a cheap
lab test, you know.
Then if they had Thank you.
If they had blood dripping out of their
nose, it'd take a $35 x-ray to see if
they had a cancer in there.
$35 bucks and a free lab test
as opposed to 421 bucks. If I wanted to
make that 421 bucks, I'd have been a
good thief. What I'd have done, I'd have
built a chute right into that CAT scan
machine cuz I knew how to build chutes
living on a farm. And I'd have gone out
in the street and I'd have got every
homeless person, I'd line them up in
them chutes, and I'd put soup in a Big
Mac at the end of that tube, you know.
And I'd say, "I'm going to get by you a
$1.50 dinner. I'm a good guy. I'm going
to buy you a $1.50 dinner. You just got
to go through this chute, go through
that tube, and you get your sandwich and
your soup."
Man, they'd be flowing through there,
maybe 100 a day.
And I could start adding some things up.
It'd be a lot of fun. Anyway, the
average doctor gets $228,660
a year in CAT scan kickbacks. A quarter
of a million dollars a year. In any
other industry, if you do that,
politicians, lawyers,
businessmen,
stockbrokers, THEY GET PUT IN JAIL.
But doctors, it's okay because insurance
pays for it. We don't mind if they steal
it blind, it's free. Remember I told you
I was going to tell you about pica?
Pica is a funny disease, pica. I'm not
talking about the type style that you
see in typewriters and computers, but
pica is a disease that farmers know
about. Uh in horses, it's called
cribbing, when they chew on the feed
bunk, the wooden feed bunk.
You know, you better give them some
minerals, otherwise they're going to eat
that feed bunk. In cattle, dairy cattle
especially, where they're losing lots of
minerals through their milk all the
time, intensive milking, uh you'll see
them picking up big rocks in the creek
and chewing on them, or they'll chew on
barbed wire, or maybe you'll see them
walking down through a path with a deer
bone in their mouth or something, or a
shingle. That's called pica. And a good
farmer or husbandry man knows you better
give them some minerals, otherwise
they're going to eat the barn or
something.
In human beings, we see this at funny
times. Pregnant women are notorious for
pica.
Uh the middle of the night they'll elbow
their husband and say, "Hey, you better
get up. I want some uh pickles and ice
cream." They're craving minerals because
that fetus is pulling minerals out of
their body. They need some more
minerals. And so it's it's recognized as
a craving for things like sweets and
salt. We see this in pregnant women. I
used to have people come to my practice
and they say, "Doctor, I need to go see
a shrink." I said, "Why is that?" "Well,
I wake up in the middle of the night and
I I go outside with a spoon and I eat
dirt." I know that's okay. Just make
sure it's clean dirt.
Then they say, "My my kid sits there
with a kitty litter box between his legs
and he has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box."
And then in housing projects, little
kids will eat lead paint off the walls
and they get lead poisoning, get
learning disabilities and bone problems
and anemia. And we're good, so we spend
$5 million to scrape the lead paint off
of there and repaint it with latex
paint. And all we have to do is give
those kids 10 cents a day worth of
minerals, it'd be better for them and
save us 5 million bucks.
It's your tax money. And if we allow
them to throw them away, those dollars,
it's kind of interesting.
If you have a selenium deficiency and
you don't want to wait until you get to
cardiomyopathy and drop dead from a
heart attack to recognize it, if you
look on your hands and look in the
mirror and your face, if you have liver
spots or age spots, and I see quite a
few from here,
you have an early selenium deficiency.
That's called free radical damage. And
fortunately for you, if you recognize
that and you start taking in some
selenium, in 4 to 6 months those will go
away. You'll reverse that in 4 to 6
months. And when they go away on the
outside, they're going away on the
inside in your brain and your heart and
your liver and your kidneys. And if you
have low blood sugar, how many in this
room have low blood sugar? Anybody in
here have low blood sugar? Okay, about
10%. How many of you ever seen a
hyperactive kid who gets on sugar?
Okay, about everybody in the room.
People who have sugar problems are like
alcoholics. There's good ones and bad
ones. You know, the good alcoholics are
one when they get two drinks they just
go off in a corner and go to sleep,
right? Same way with somebody with low
blood sugar. They eat a big meal or they
eat a piece of pie, 3 hours later they
conk out and go to sleep. Then there's
bad alcoholics. They're the one that
gets two drinks in them and they get
violent and raged and they want to fight
everybody, punch holes in the wall, you
know, big brave fellows and they kick
their wife and kick the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbor's tree
down and all these wild things and drive
reckless down the roads and kill people.
Those are the bad drunks. Well, people
who have blood sugar problems, there's
bad blood sugar people, too. They get a
little crazy. Okay, I don't know how
many of you remember the Twinkie
defense.
Right? Remember where somebody murdered
two people and he claimed he ate a
Twinkie 3 hours before he murdered them,
so they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar. Now, don't any of you try that.
Well, chromium and vanadium deficiency
will result in these sugar problems. Low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes.
Chromium and vanadium. Then a tin
deficiency, the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency are male pattern baldness.
I see a lot of tin deficiency in this
room.
Yes.
And if you let it go on for any length
of time, you get deafness.
Then there's a boron deficiency and you
gals should know about boron because it
helps you keep the calcium you take in
in your bones so you don't get
osteoporosis.
Boron. Also, it helps you make estrogen.
It helps you fellows make testosterone.
If you don't take in enough boron, you
ladies are going to suffer miserably
going through menopause. Okay, you're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms.
You fellows don't get enough boron,
can't make testosterone, you won't know
whether to lead or follow on the dance
floor.
You're going to be confused.
She's saying, "He's got a boron
deficiency.
The first symptoms of a zinc deficiency
is you lose your sense of smell and your
taste. You say, "Oh, you know, food just
doesn't taste good anymore." And you
don't have a cold or anything like that.
And you say
your wife says, "Well, aren't you
excited about dinner? I spent the whole
day in the kitchen cooking dinner." He
says, "Well, I didn't smell anything
when I walked in." You know he's got a
zinc deficiency.
On laboratory animals, there's some
seven rare earths. These rare earths are
trace minerals you need in lesser
amounts than you need trace minerals.
And they actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals. They've not been
proven in humans yet, but I'm not going
to wait 500 years for doctors to approve
it. They're still arguing over vitamin C
and calcium, right? So, I'm just going
to do it. Didn't kill any laboratory
animals. It just doubles your life and
it's not a drug.
These rare earths are called lanthanum,
praseodymium, neodymium, samarium,
europium, ytterbium, and thulium. There
must be a reason why they're named after
Old Testament cities. Well, remember I
told you we needed 90 nutrients. We need
60 minerals. We need 16 vitamins, 12
essential amino acids, and three
essential fatty acids. And of course,
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins, amino acids, and
fatty acids. Plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins,
amino acids, and fatty acids. But you
have to eat 15 to 25 different plants a
day in the right combinations to make
this happen. Theoretically, it's
possible, but most Americans don't do
it. The average American thinks if they
eat some potato buds out of a Betty
Crocker box, they're eating a vegetable.
Okay? So, you got to be careful what
you're considering a vegetable.
Then, of course, uh people want to do
right by their doctor and they eat
low-fat turkey breast and they put a
half a jar of mayonnaise on there. And
they put it between two slices of Wonder
Styrofoam bread.
Remember that stuff you can insulate
your house with and put in your shoes
when you get a hole in shoe? I remember
when I was a kid, it was a lot of fun
because we have Wonder Bread. We didn't
have TVs back then on the farm. We
didn't even have dryers that went round
and round. So, the only thing you could
do in the wintertime was sit in the
kitchen and wonder at a loaf of Wonder
Bread. And it had the blue and red and
green and yellow balloons on there. And
if you read the label as many times as I
do, you know it said things like helps
build bodies in 12 ways.
And about 15 years later the FDA made
them change it to help build your body
eight ways. Now if you go to the store
and look at Wonder Bread wrappers, it
just says Wonder Bread. So it kind of
gives you a clue.
So even though this is theoretically
possible, it's not likely to happen that
you're going to get your vitamins, amino
acids, and fatty acids in proper
proportions from your diet. And so if
your life is as valuable to you as mine
is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me,
I would make sure that I take in all my
vitamins and amino acids and fatty acids
because I guarantee you won't make it to
120 if you don't.
You're just not going to do it.
Now minerals are another story. We have
a tragic story when it comes to minerals
because
plants cannot make minerals in any way,
shape, or form. And if they're not in
the soil anymore, they're not in our
plants. Our farm soils and our range
soils are depleted of minerals. And the
crops, the grains, the fruits and the
vegetables, and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm and range soils
are minerally deficient. And the people
who eat them get mineral deficiency
diseases. And the only way to prevent
and cure them is with mineral
supplements. Do you think it's gotten
any better?
No. It has not gotten any better. It's
only gotten worse. And the reason is if
you guys do what we did and and people
continue to do, is we put NPK on our
land,
nitrogen, phosphorus, potassium. And you
see it as these three numbers in many
combinations of ratios. And these
represent percentages of these three
nutrients, nitrogen, phosphorus,
potassium. And those of you who don't
have any experience on farms, the reason
why we do this is farmers get paid for
tons and bushels. There's no subsidy
that encourages people to put 60
minerals back in the soil. You get paid
for tons and bushels. And for 40 bucks
an acre, you can get the maximum yield
in tons and bushels. It only takes 5 to
10 years to deplete the land of
minerals, cuz every time you harvest a
crop, those plants pull minerals out of
the soil, many pounds per acre every
time you haul a crop out. So, as soon
those minerals are gone. And if you only
put back in three and you take out 60,
it's like a checking account. If you
only put three bucks in your checking
account every month and write checks for
60, what's going to happen to your
checks? Boing, boing, boing, they
bounce, exactly. Well, I can tell you
that our health is bouncing right now to
the tune of 1.2 trillion dollars a year.
It's our responsibility, each and every
one of us, to be responsible for our
health and consciously taking these
minerals. Well, I have a lot of people
ask me, "Well, what did these people do
thousands of years ago? They didn't even
have commercial fertilizers. What did
they do, these societies that had
long-lived people and whatnot?" I want
you to think about the Egyptians, the
Chinese, people from India that lived
around these great rivers, the Nile
River, the Ganges River, the Yellow
River in China. And what used to happen
was every year or so it flood, just like
it did here in northern Missouri
last year.
And every time it flooded, guess what
would happen? It would bring silt or
rock dust from mountains from 500 or
1,000 miles away, and those people would
pray to every god they had, the water
god, the sky god, the wind god, the rock
god, to flood. We pray, "Don't flood."
They used to pray to flood because they
had their floods during the winter time,
and it would put silt and minerals back
in the soil, and their grain was very
valuable. King Philip, who is the father
of uh Alexander the Great, married the
12-year-old child queen of Egypt,
Cleopatra. She didn't look like
Elizabeth Taylor, all made up in
beautiful costumes. She was a little
flat-chested teenybopper, not very sexy,
but Philip married her because
she controlled the best wheat in the
world. And if he wanted his Macedonian
army to conquer the world through his
son, Alexander the Great, he needed the
best wheat in the world so he could
march 20 hours a day, fight for 6 hours,
and win. If they used the wheat from the
depleted soils in Greece, they couldn't
go 20 minutes without saying, "Mommy,
pick me up." Can you imagine these big
Greek soldiers, "Oh, my legs hurt. Pick
me up."
And so, they knew the best place to get
wheat was from Egypt.
It was those floods that gave them those
minerals. And all those cultures that
came up with all the great art and all
the great technology came from those
places because they had more
intelligence cuz they had more
nutrition, more minerals. I heard
somebody say, "Very good." Well, you're
getting the picture. Well, what I'm
going to do here is I'm just going to
pick out a couple of minerals, just a
couple of them, so you get the idea. It
applies to all of them. Let's just pick
out a common one, like calcium.
Everybody knows about calcium. Calcium
deficiency will result in something like
147 different diseases.
They're just different names. They're
named after people, like Bell's palsy.
You know, everybody knows about that.
One side of your face sags. It's not a
true stroke. It just affects your facial
muscles. It's caused by calcium
deficiency. We'll talk about it in a
little bit. But everybody knows about
this one, osteoporosis.
It's the number 10 killer of adults in
the United States. It's very expensive.
It costs you $35,000 each for each hip
to replace. It's okay. It's free.
Insurance will pay for it. Costs you
$70,000 for both hips. As expensive as
it is, and the number 10 killer,
remember?
Mrs. Skeats from Radford, Virginia, aged
115 years of age. She died of
complications of a fall.
We don't have osteoporosis in animals,
and it's because of farmers we don't
have osteoporosis in animals. Goes like
this. You have a a pasture with 100 cows
in it. And this year you didn't have any
calves. You can't repay your operating
loan. You're in trouble.
Right? Cuz you paid for the feed and the
vet bill and mowed the pasture and
fertilized and maintained the fence and
fed the cows and all this, that, and the
other. You don't have any calves. You
can't pay back the operating loan and
make any money. So, you call the vet out
and you say, "Do I get rid of these
cows? What happened here?" And he
examines the cows. He says, "Nothing
wrong with them." He says, "Let me look
at the bull." He says, "Aha, here's your
problem. That bull has osteoporosis of
both hips. Can't breed the cows. Didn't
have any calves." He says, "I'll tell
you what though." He says, "You give me
$70,000." He says, "I'll put two new
hips in that bull and next year you'll
have some calves."
Well, the first thing that farmer says
is stand back, doc. Boom!
He blows that bull away with a deer
rifle. And while the kids are grinding
the bull up with a grinder and cutting
roast and steaks off that bull, the
farmer's chewing on a straw and saying,
"Now, doc." Pushes his Stetson up a
little bit and he says,
"You know I wasn't going to pay you
$70,000 for that old boy. He says, "I
can get a new bull every year for 70
years for that." He says, "But every
once in a while I get a bull that throws
good calves. I'd like to keep them. Is
there any way I can prevent that
osteoporosis thing for happening to a
good bull?" He says, "Well, yeah." He
says, "If you'll give a bull calf 10
cents worth of calcium every day after
he's weaned, he'll never get
osteoporosis." Farmer says, "Now, wait a
minute, doc." "You mean if I give that
bull 10 cents a day worth of calcium
from the time he's weaned, I can prevent
a $70,000
disaster?" He says, "Oh, yeah. It's that
simple." He says, "You mean all I have
to do is give up a half a cup of coffee
a day to do that?" He says, "Yeah,
that's it." He says, "I choose that
one."
He says, "I'll give up the half a cup of
coffee." And that's what we have to
think like. Then there's receding gums.
Dentists and periodontists will tell you
that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums, you better floss and
brush after every meal. If you believe
that works, I have some oceanfront
property in Montana to sell you.
If you all know your geography, you know
that doesn't work. As a veterinarian,
I've seen hundreds of thousands of
animals of all kinds. Mice, rats,
rabbits, dogs, cats, sheep, pigs,
horses, lions, and tigers, and bears,
and they don't get receding gums.
And they don't floss.
Now, they do get funky breath, but they
don't get receding gums.
Well, if you want to smell something,
you just let a camel breathe on you,
boy.
Well, the reason we don't have receding
gums in livestock is because we've dealt
with the osteoporosis problem. Receding
gums is not a deficiency of flossing,
it's in fact osteoporosis of the jaw
bones and of the facial bones. So, if
you have gingivitis or receding gums,
you have advanced osteoporosis. Those
bones around your teeth are melting away
little bit by little bit every day. And
if you take your teeth out at night and
put them in a glass next to your bed and
that fizzy stuff, you have major
advanced osteoporosis because all your
bone has melted away.
Then there's arthritis. We talked about
that a little bit earlier. Remember the
chicken cartilage? 85% of all arthritis
is caused by osteoporosis of the joint
ends of the bones. You're talking about
degenerative arthritis, osteoarthritis,
sciatica, lumbago, rheumatism, all those
sorts of things.
Um they're caused by osteoporosis of the
joint ends of the bones. I want you to
think about something for a minute. If
you don't take a pain reliever or or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis,
let's say you get arthritis of the hips,
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit, aren't you? You're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches.
You're going to
favor it, so you don't put any weight on
it. I want you to think about that for
just a second because then I want you to
think about driving your tractor in a
field or you're driving a Mercedes down
the highway, either one, doesn't matter.
Whichever you love more.
Let's say you didn't put the nut on that
oil pan real tight and all the oil
drained out.
And that light on the dashboard comes on
says, "I'm getting hot, you better give
me some oil."
And that light irritates you. So, you
stop, you open up the hood, you get your
clippers out, you know, your fence
clippers, and you clip the wire to that
light, and you close the hood, and you
just keep driving.
Would you do that to your tractor or
your Mercedes? No, you wouldn't.
But we take those pain relievers for
arthritis, and we go out there and
square dance, and do the Texas two-step,
and do our 5-mi walks and our aerobics.
That pill works real good, Doc, cuz it
killed my pain. And you're just wearing
that thing off faster and faster. Then
your doctor's really going to get rich
because you need joint replacement
surgery. Then there's hypertension. This
is one of my favorites, so I'll put a
star over here. Hypertension is high
blood pressure. What's the first
nutritional thing that a doctor will
tell you to give up nutritionally when
you get high blood pressure? Give up
salt. Everybody knows that one. That's
been ingrained in our head. Well, they
must think we're dumber than cows
because what's the first thing you put
out for your livestock is about that
big, a salt block. No farmer is going to
be economically viable if you don't put
a salt block out for your livestock.
They're going to die. Kind of your your
veterinary bills are going to go crazy.
But we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt. You can get everything
you need out of your lettuce and your
whole wheat bread and stuff like that.
Well, don't believe that one either. If
you believe that, I got some more
oceanfront property in Montana for you.
They took $30 million of your tax money
and 2 years ago after 20 year study,
they came out and said that they took
5,000 people with high blood pressure,
they took them off their medication and
put them on a reduced salt diet, a
restricted salt diet, and they all died.
No big surprise, but somebody got a PhD
degree and everybody was happy, right?
But when they looked at this results,
they said that only 99.7%
of the people didn't get any results
from that before they died. 0.3% did get
some result, dropped their blood
pressure one point before they died by
restricting their salt. So, the referees
who judged that article said, "Oh,
doesn't matter. You might as well let
high blood pressure patients eat salted
peanuts and dill pickles and salt their
food to taste because it doesn't matter.
In fact, worrying about the salt is more
stress than taking the salt." Then they
had a control group with 5,000 people
with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of calcium and they
stopped the experiment in 6 weeks
because 85% of them were cured of their
high blood pressure just by doubling
their calcium intake. Now, they didn't
cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication, but what they did
was they went to the doctor and said,
"You don't need this medication anymore.
What are you doing?" He said, "Well, I'm
on this experiment where I double my
calcium intake." Anybody get a recall
notice from your doctor saying it's okay
to salt your food to taste and please do
double your calcium intake. Anybody get
that? Not a single one. That's very
interesting. Then, of course, there's uh
insomnia. That's where you roll around
all night. You wake up in the morning,
you're more tired when you went to bed.
And that's insomnia. Of course, doctors
have two treatments for that. They have
Halcion, which is a sleeping pill, and
they have barbiturates. They kill about
10,000 people a year with overdoses of
those things, but that's okay. It's a
prescription, and they're watching out
for us.
And remember George Bush when he went to
Japan, they gave him some Halcion so he
could sleep on the way to Japan cuz of
the time difference. And when he woke
up, one of the side effects of Halcion
is nausea and vomiting.
I don't know how you say it in Japanese,
but it was very dramatic on world TV,
right? Not very presidential.
And so, I'm sure that's why he lost the
election because he puked over that
Japanese ambassador.
And then, of course, there's kidney
stones. And then, there is a bone spurs,
heel spurs, and calcium deposits. Again,
physicians will tell you
the first thing to give up nutritionally
is calcium and dairy because they have
this foolish belief, the stupid belief,
the ignorant belief that the calcium in
kidney stones, bone spurs, heel spurs,
and calcium deposits come from your diet
when instead it only comes from your
bones when you have a raging
osteoporosis. And when you get these
things, you need more calcium, not less.
Then, there's cramps and twitches. You
wake up in the middle of the night and
your foot is all cramped up around your
neck, and you say, "Lord, take me from
the knee down. I'm not going to make it
till morning." We've all experienced
that.
That's very common.
Then, there's PMS, premenstrual
syndrome.
You know, the emotional and physical
stuff. The medical treatment of choice
for PMS is what we call a hysterical
ectomy. It's been shortened to
hysterectomy. That's a 100-year-old
treatment. And they uh doctors do about
285,000 unnecessary hysterical ectomies
a year, but it makes Mercedes payments,
so they do them. Even the AMA said
they're unnecessary, but they don't take
their licenses away and people keep
going to them. You imagine a poor woman
in her 30s she says, "Doc, you got to do
something. Every time I go out to hang
out the clothes and my neighbor's kids
run down the basement screaming witch.
My own kids think I'm crazy. My
husband's leaving me. I'm going to lose
my job. You got to do something." Well,
the University of California, San Diego
came out 3 years ago now and said if you
just double the RDA of calcium intake
you get rid of 85% of the emotional and
physical symptoms of PMS. And when that
came out there were huge lines around
the health food stores around the blocks
and people had sleeping bags cuz they
closed before they all got their calcium
and every person in line was a man.
They were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that. Okay, and lastly is
low back pain. 85% of Americans get low
back pain whether you work on a computer
or you unload hay or you drive big
trucks doesn't matter. Low back is a big
problem. Low back is just osteoporosis
of the vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or what not because if your disc
doesn't have anything to hold on to,
your vertebrae have melted away, what's
going to happen to the disc? Especially
if you have a copper deficiency because
they're made out of elastic fibers. They
go like a water balloon with a lot of
pressure on them. I just want you to
look at this quickly before we do the
last mineral. Low back you go to an
orthopedic surgeon or rheumatologist you
might get a muscle relaxant. You might
get Valium and a muscle relaxant. You
get a laminectomy. You get your
vertebrae fused. You might get a disc
operation. They don't tell you 75% of
the time you'll never be the same again.
Right? PMS you go to your OBGYN. You can
go to an internist. You can go to a
family counselor, a shrink or divorce
attorney. Cramps and twitches you go to
a neurologist. You go to a sports
medicine doctor, an internist. Bone
spurs, heel spurs, calcium deposits you
go to a rheumatologist, an orthopedic
surgeon or a podiatrist.
Kidney stones you go to a urologist or
an internist or a surgeon. Insomnia you
go to a shrink or a sleep clinic or an
internist. Hypertension, you go to a
cardiologist and internist or a surgeon.
Arthritis, a rheumatologist, a
orthopedic surgeon or an internist.
Receding gums, you go to a dentist or
periodontist. Osteoporosis, you go to
all those health specialists including a
tums salesman.
For nothing more than a calcium
deficiency. It costs you 10 cents a day
to deal with. Now, on the average
because Americans have insurance and we
have Medicare and Medicaid, we spend on
the average $25,000 to $250,000
and we undergo five to 10 surgical
procedures a year for a calcium
deficiency and we beg the doctors to do
it. We beg the doctors to do it. Well,
it's our choice. The last one I'll share
with you is diabetes. Everybody's
touched by diabetes. It's the number
three cause of death in adults in the
United States. Number three cause of
death and it has terrible complications
and side effects. Diabetes. The side
effects include blindness of many kinds.
Then there is a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant. There's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds and
of course that contributes to number one
cause of death. Then there is
amputations. Everybody ought to have one
of those cuz they're totally paid for in
their health thing. Because they assume
that you're not just going to get one
cuz you want to get everything on your
health benefits. And then you shorten
your life because if you have diabetes
on the average, you have a shorter
lifespan than someone who doesn't have
diabetes. Now,
we learned in 1957
in the animal industry that we could
prevent and cure diabetes with two trace
minerals.
That's pretty profound statement that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals in 1957 in animals. It
was published in Federation Proceedings,
which is the official journal of the
American Science. The National
Institutes of Health. The official
monthly journal was August 1957.
Well, the two trace minerals that you
can get to prevent and cure this, are
chromium and vanadium. Vanadium alone,
according to the University of
Vancouver, British Columbia Medical
School, vanadium alone will replace
insulin in adult onset diabetics, which
represent 85% of all diabetics. Course,
they can't quit their insulin cold
turkey. They got to gradually wean off
of it. Takes 4 to 6 months for most
people to slowly wean off of insulin if
they're taking in adequate amounts of
chromium and vanadium. Now, to me, this
is criminal. Because if you write to uh
Hill's Packing Company that makes
Science Diet dog food, they're right
over here in Topeka, Kansas. So, they
manufacture Science Diet dog food and
other Science Diet product, high-tech
foods for animals.
If you write them and say, "How many
minerals exactly is in Science Diet for
dog food?" They'll write you back and
say there's 40 minerals.
You write to Checkerboard Square in St.
Louis, Ralston Purina, say, "Just how
many minerals are in your rat pellets
for laboratory rats?" And they'll say
there's 28 minerals. I'll give anybody
in this room a crisp new $100 bill if
you can find me a human infant formula
in a grocery store that has more than
11. So, our dogs get 40 minerals.
Remember, that's what Mike Murphy was
saying. His dog never seems to get sick
cuz he's getting this canned dog food
with all these vitamins and minerals in
there. So, our dogs get 40 minerals, our
rats get 28 minerals, and our human
infants get 11.
Is that fair?
No, that's called fraud.
Doesn't matter if you're talking about
SMA, Similac, Isomil, ProSobee. In fact,
that's why they call Similac Similac,
cuz it lacks everything.
Okay, if I've convinced you that you
have to consciously take in all the
minerals yourself, that you can't depend
on your food, and certainly can't depend
on anything that's boxed or packaged or
bottled,
there's three types of minerals that you
have to be concerned about. One is
metallic minerals. Metallic minerals are
essentially ground up rocks. Metallic
minerals are things like oyster shell,
egg shell, dolomite, limestone, uh
calcium carbonate, clays of various
kinds, montmorillonite clay, seabed
minerals, Tums.
They're only 8 to 12% absorbable. When
you reach age 35 to 40, it drops down to
3 to 5% and I have to tell you a story
here.
I ran into a guy at a meeting like this
up at Grand Rapids, Michigan and this
fellow owns a Porta Potty business. You
know, that's that green or blue colored
outhouse. Man, if we'd only had one of
those back when I was a kid. We had
these ones with splinters, you know, in
the wood. He said, "I see something that
that describes that in my Porta Potty
business." I said, "What's that?" He
says, "Well, when we take those things
back to the shop to clean them out with
a pressure hose." He says, "We put a
1/4 inch grid underneath them because
kids throw rocks and sticks and toys in
there and if we don't put a grid there,
it blocks up the sewer system. It costs
us thousands of dollars to fix it."
"Every time we clean one of those out,
we find hundreds of vitamin tablets."
I said, "Well, how do you know they're
vitamin tablets?" He said, "Well, that's
really easy." He says, "Right on the
coating it says Theragran M, one a day,
Centrum."
He says, "Come here." He takes me out in
the back of the shop and there's this
literal mountain
of all these vitamin pills he got out of
his Porta Potties. If you read the
labels on those multiples, they say
your iron that comes in the form of iron
oxide.
What is iron oxide? Rust.
You might as well just go out to an old
railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're going to get your
iron supplement. That's what they're
giving you.
Uh show you how bad it is. If you take
something like calcium lactate, which is
which is a common metallic mineral.
Let's say it's a calcium tablet, calcium
lactate 1,000 mg. If you take two of
those, you're not getting 2,000 mg of
calcium. In fact, I have people all the
time say, "Well, I took lots of calcium,
doc. I hear you on the radio talking
about calcium and arthritis and I took
2,000 mg of calcium a day. It didn't
help my arthritis. In fact, it got
worse." I said, "What kind of calcium
you taking?" He said, "Calcium lactate."
Well, there's your problem because only
250 mg of that is metallic calcium. So,
let's say you absorb 10% of that, then
the other 750 mg is lactose or milk
sugar. So, 10% of 250 is 25, so if you
take two of those tablets, you're not
getting 2,000, you're getting 50 mg.
So, to get what you need, you need to
take 90 of those tablets a day. You need
to take 30 with each meal, and you got
59 more minerals to go.
Then there's those people who want to do
things naturally. Let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 lb of spinach.
And let's be fair, let's see if you can
get 1,000 mg of magnesium. I picked
magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables, you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll, right? It's
part of the chlorophyll molecule. And
any pound of anything, you got 454 g,
and 10 lb of spinach, you got 4,540 g,
of which most of that, 97% is water.
Let's say you have 1 g of chlorophyll in
that 10 lb of spinach, there's 50 mg of
magnesium. You got to divide that into
the thousand you want, you get a factor
of 20, which you multiply times the 10,
you have to eat 200 lb of spinach, you
got 58 more minerals to go.
Okay, so
you got to be a pretty big person to
accomplish all this. Even as big as I
am, you can't get it done. So, I prefer
to supplement rather than do those
things.
Then of course, during the '60s, the
agricultural industry came up with
chelated minerals, because farmers
aren't dumb enough to pay for a dollar
of something that goes into an animal's
mouth and have 99 cents come out in the
manure.
I have to really thank farmers for being
that clever. And chelated minerals are
just metallic minerals with an amino
acid or protein or enzyme wrapped around
the metal atom. It increased the
absorbability to 40%.
Then the health food industry jumped on
that right away, cuz it was a major
improvement in absorbability of
minerals.
The most efficient way to absorb
minerals is liquid. They're very small
particle size, and are 7,000 times
smaller than a red blood cell, and
they're negatively charged, so you
actually have an electrical or magnetic
gradient that concentrates these
minerals. Plants have a very interesting
part to play in colloidal minerals.
Remember we said that plants cannot
create minerals. If they're not in the
soil, plants can't make them.
Anyway, metallic minerals are taken up
by plants when they're in the soil.
Plants convert them in their tissues to
colloidal minerals, and this is how we
store minerals in our body. This is how
we use minerals in our body. This is how
we transport minerals from the storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal farm. Well, our plants our
crops don't have much in the way of
colloidal minerals in them cuz we don't
have any metallic minerals in our soil.
Are these minerals important? You bet
your life they're important.